>> OH, GOOD.
>> GET UP!
THAT'S CALLED TEBOWING AND IT'S
ONE MORE REASON TO HATE TIM
TEBOW.
BEFORE AND AFTER EVERY GAME, HE
TAKES A KNEE AND REFLECTS WITH
GOD.
BUT IF TEBOW WAS REALLY A GOOD
CHRISTIAN HE'D HONOR THE SABBATH
AND KEEP IT HOLY BY NOT WORKING
EVERY SUNDAY.
I GET THAT TEBOW'S A LEADER ON
THE FIELD, BUT YOU KNOW WHO'D BE
EVEN BETTER IN A HUDDLE?
A PROFESSIONAL QUARTERBACK.
HE'S NOT A PASSER WHO'S A THREAT
TO RUN.
HE'S A TIGHT END WHO LINES UP IN
THE WILDCAT.
HE SEEMED GOOD IN COLLEGE
BECAUSE HE WAS SHOTPUTTING
6-YARD DUMP SCREENS TO A SAFETY
VALVE.
OH, HE WON THE HEISMAN?
GREAT, SO DID CHARLIE WARD, AND
HE SAT ON THE KNICKS BENCH FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
HE'S THE ONLY ATHLETE WHO BRAGS
ABOUT BEING A VIRGIN.
AT LEAST TONY ROMO BANGS DUDES.
KNOCK IT OFF WITH THE BIBLE
VERSES AND ABSTINENCE TALK.
I HAVE IT ON GOOD AUTHORITY THAT
YOUR V-CARD GOT SWIPED PLENTY
DOWN IN GAINESVILLE.
DENVER IS BETTER OFF WITHOUT
HIM, BUT TRY TELLING THAT TO A
STADIUM FULL OF CHANTING HILL
PEOPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
EVERYONE IS TEBOWING THESE DAYS,
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT REALLY MEANS.
WHEN YOU DROP DOWN IN PRAYER
LIKE HIM, IT SHOULD BE AFTER
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING AWFUL,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT TIM TEBOW
REPRESENTS, BEING AWFUL.
[LAUGHTER]
[BOOING]
>> WHO TEBOWS AFTER TAKING A
DUMP?
>> I'M